okay no word from an April I need a
status report how's it looking out there
perfect but just one thing it's not a
basketball court anymore it's a nice
gating rink wait what why what happened
super guy called to book this place and
tell me they took off the basketball
floor for a hockey game or maybe he did
tell me what he was so stupid and boring
that I wasn't listening and either way
it was his fault because he was stupid I
hated him run how's the stage coming
well since we had to jettison the bulk
of the wood and this is the biggest I
could make it oh my god good lord what
happened to the rest of my face we had
two Jetsons most of the poster - but I
kind of like it cuz windows are the eyes
to the house Wow okay hey God Pistol
Pete good where is he right now he's
curled up in the backseat of my car
talking about his father who was a piece
of work I actually think he did the best
he could for a single father but I may
be too close to this situation anyway
the important news is that he's here
good is he gonna dunk for me I'm not
sure
I couldn't hear through all that crying
he's crying no I was crying it's been a
stressful day and he's had a really
rough life oh my god we should cancel it
right maybe we should cancel him Jerry
you were in charge of getting a crowd
please tell me that you pulled a Jerry
and no one's here okay well first of all
I don't like it when you guys use that
term for the record I came through there
are almost a hundred people out there
damn it Jerry you just had to do your
job didn't you yeah can't you do
anything wrong Jerry I've been looking
at our utter and complete lack of
experience as a positive thing but I'm
starting to think it might actually be a
problem
okay guys everybody listen up I just
wanted to say thank you you've all
volunteered your time and no matter what
I am eternally grateful for it now I am
gonna go out there and I'm going to
announce the relaunch and I'm gonna
muddle through this thing as best I can
you should all leave and when this thing
is over I'll meet you at the nearest bar
that would be Hurley's oh it's karaoke
tonight yes no no guys no we're not
leaving okay we're the reason Leslie's
in this mess it's our mess we're gonna
stay here and we're gonna go out there
as a team or we go as a team to Hurley's
no Ann's right we're a team
we're all going out together let's give
this crowd a show
[Applause]
Tom I couldn't afford enough premium
carpet to get us his stage I mean it's a
short walk but it was pretty luxurious
right okay everybody smile away
[Music]
I'm holding the dog his page is now
peeing and putting him down
[Music]
[Music]
as a loyal pawneean I've always been
proud of this town and I sorry my cards
got out of order here when they fell um
together we can defeat obese children
I'm sure that was something positive
originally I'm sorry okay this is this
is just a disaster isn't it this is the
worst political event ever in history
well I can assure you people in the
bleachers that if you follow my campaign
it will be interesting it sure will be
ladies and gentlemen I'm Pistol Pete and
around here I'm a carny
I just wanted to say that I fully
endorse Leslie Knope she's got a great
team behind her and a vote for her is a
slam dunk everybody still got
[Music]
you